like a charm before
now it works
great
yeah thank you for for having me here um
i thought i'll present some
combination of some data we generate and
also the analytical questions so i hope
i i have something interesting for for
for the breadth of the audience um in
different areas before i get into the
actual topic which is actually quite
related to what the video is presenting
i want to also just sort of motivate a
few sort of tools we're using at the
backbone that i'll need to start out
with so we have a very strong interest
in obviously leveraging different
technologies you know the drive novel
methodologies i'm not going to talk
about spatial assets today although that
would be uh also a very interesting
interest for us i want to talk a little
bit about you know using multi-ohmic
data in in also in the context of
spatial and temporal covariate like here
as an example
triple ohmic sequencing where we measure
multiple omics layers from the same
cells and and and the reason is that
there's sort of two elements that we
took away from this that also in the
remainder of my presentation be very
useful um the first is it it's been
turned out very important
and and also sort of complicated and
something i think we sometimes also
underestimate sort of to sort of the
engineering you know to align different
matrices of um rna and attack profiles
from you know later on i'll talk later
with hundreds of samples and and putting
these together and we've been um
engaging in these activities and also
thinking about the software
infrastructure and i think it would be
also it's quite a useful exercise to
think about how to do this as a
community and there's maybe this
consortium sebas or the python users you
might want to take a look at
that and that is with others to make
these things interoperable
the other side i want to quickly mention
because i will use this quite
extensively is factorizations of data
and i'm not going to say much i think it
has been mentioned in several talks but
at several occasions that will also you
know use now tools where we
co-factorize using group fact analysis
multimodalities that we have observed in
parallel here for example using the
example that we have you know
methylation transcriptomic accessibility
from the same cells and and the core
what i'm going to care about for this
talk is really this latent
representation that's shared that we map
these cells in a latent space you know
factors that we're going to you know use
quite a bit in this and i'm happy also
discuss offline there's i think quite
exciting questions also how we
incorporate spatial and temporal
covariate these types of approaches um
but that's not for this talk
what i really want to focus on is you
know um a sort of technology that came
our way um a few years ago that really
enabled scaling single cell sequencing
to generating data from hundreds of
people and and what we can do with that
and that actually
sparked a lot of interest because it's
actually why we got engaged in the field
because it allows us addressing
questions in human genetics and i have
also a few slides of background why this
question is of relevance and then
what approaches we've been taking to to
tackle them
and so the the real motivator is maybe
represented by this slide this is a
picture from the g bus catalog
and you know these different structures
here human
chromosomes every dot here is a
disease or feeling betrayed we've been
mapped to heritable variants in our
genome i guess most of you familiar with
this type of representation so we
essentially have mappings between
variants and disease traits of all sorts
that can be as benign as yearbooks type
or eye color or disease risk for
something you really don't want to have
in advanced age and what we now really
want to do is figure out what are the
molecular intermediates that sit
causally ideally between varian and
phenotype
and mediate or mitigate that signal and
then also confer targets for
intervention and ultimately develop
treatments
and i use this picture to represent this
problem that i i hope will help to get
us on the same page
so on the right hand side here variant
to phenotype that's actually what genome
organization studies do for example
quotes like uk biobank i'm not going to
really talk about this here but the key
is we need hundreds of thousands of
samples and these associations are plus
minus
you know persistent robust there's a bit
of g by e
but it's it's you know you can it's a
regression problem we can we can but
understand and linking variants to
phenotypes
and what i want to focus on is the other
side of this diagram which is linking
these variants to molecular readouts
like expression changes of genes
and that has a
positive and a negative aspect to it the
positive is
we can do this in much smaller cohorts
so hundreds of people is often enough
and the reason is that these molecular
effects on expenditures and gene
expression are much stronger now you
have a lot more power to detect those
changes so that's the good news
the bad news is that this association is
incredibly in robust in the sense of it
really depends on which cell type cell
stage you're measuring them you need to
find the right cell type the right time
development to look at this i'm having
here this bio the diagram from the
um
lifetime white paper which are quite
like it shows that we really want to
look at using single cell assets where
in life of trajectory cells mitigate and
propagate and you need to at the right
time basically assess this association
yeah and and that is um
quite a challenge in figuring out how
you go from variant to expression and
how to look at that so this is where
single cell assets come in i'm talking
just like a few more slides about data
before i can come to the model um so we
combined ips derived models where we
take ips cells differentiable to
different lineages i'm talking about
neurons in this case here and on the
other hand single cell sequencing that
really allows you to capture this
complexity of cell types as they emerge
and that we then can understand you know
how do these variations in our genome
then link to expression changes and then
we can also go back all the way to
disease variants at the end
so a few years ago we we set this up
with um with uh
[Music]
florian merkler and gaffney the sanger
in cambridge
and the approach we took we took 215
people
and so this is the diversity of
individuals from which we had ips cell
lines
so it's not a super large end but
substantial
and we created pools of human ips cell
lines and i i mentioned this pooling
here will become later on i hope i can
close the loop in time
and and basically what this experiment
conducts are just 10 pools of 20 lines
each so this whole data set are 10
different stations
and that's exciting because you
obviously can do this very efficiently
we differentiate these pools towards
this neuronal fate details don't really
matter but we collect cells at day 11 30
and 52 and then collect the quite
substantial delays of a million cells or
something like that we can look at
so one note about pooling
i think many of you here in the single
cell will be using this
in different contexts
in a way the pooling is is is in our
case
straightforwardly resolved because these
lines are generally diverse so you can
assay variants in your single cell and
seek data these data are extremely
sparse but given that any one of the
pair of lines has roughly 10 000
variants segregating between there's
more than enough information now you
find these 10 20 variants that allow you
to say oh yeah this cell comes from this
guy this cell comes from this guy so you
can resolve that and and there's also
work from from jimmy and others
pioneering pooling methods um in this
context i also want to mention that this
is great on the one hand because you get
more throughput and lower batch effects
but there's a downside which you create
very uneven representations of samples
you don't get the same numbers of cells
from each individual that's something to
deal with in the analysis downstream
so this is the data we will be getting
so we're starting with these blue guys
here these are magenta cells then here
there are neurons occurring these green
populations we care about in the end and
they also actually mature but i want to
emphasize that of subtle changes of how
cells change across differentiation um
and that's something i won't come back
to later what is actually a neuron and
and what are these cell types and is it
is it sensible to cluster these cells
discretely but for for this purpose
we're doing this there's many questions
we could offer this i just want to
mention two
major insights that we took away from
this the first is
and that's exactly
is quite important for downstream
questions is actually not all these
lines make neurons in the same way there
are some lines that basically barely
make any 20 efficiency in a way while
others make them at high proportions
but that's not for this talk what i
really want to focus on but there is a
connection
is that we can use this data and then
map genetic effects so here these green
populations for example here these are
dopamine neural neurons
and what we're and these guys here are
serotogenic neurons and what i'm showing
here is just sort of stereotypical
example how we map these qtls is
expression level of a particular gene
and now what we essentially do is in
this population here
pseudo bulk or aggregate across
all cells from one particular individual
so every dot here in this in this in
this cartoon is a person is a line and
asking whether those individuals carry a
particular allele change in expression
and here you can see presence of an
association or absence of association in
a different case
um there's one detail that i want to
mention
and that is quite important that's
exactly caused by these unequal sampling
so what we are doing i come to that
later on a little bit more detail is
actually fitting random effect models
where we really count explicitly for the
fact that one we have multiple repeat
lines from the same person that's the
one relatedness you need to account for
the second is that you've a lot less
information about these guys than these
guys so really your noise properties are
extremely skewed you need to really
think about what what properties you
actually measure and what what you don't
measure and this is a this is a really
that's the surprise to pay for pooling
from pooling many lives
and i i want to just sort of show you
one example here you know for those who
care about the sort of downstream
biological implication we can actually
find a number of interesting
co-localization event here is one hit
for schizophrenia
so these are variance risk for
schizophrenic outcomes later in life and
the same pool of variants that are here
downstream of this gene sfx and five are
also associated with expression changes
with the
statistical evidence for co-localization
in our data in this particular condition
for example they don't show up in gta so
you can really drill in really this very
fine defined cell sometimes understand
what is going on
so far so good so what's the statistical
question well
anna and tobias in the lab they thought
about this problem and you know what i
talked about essentially is solving lots
of regression problems we want to fit a
cessation between variance and
expression
and you know we a non-zero slope is all
we care about in in molecular genetics
and we can do this across cell types for
example setup a
celta b and there is a slope that
changes and you know that might hint
towards an interaction effect that your
cell type modulates the way genetics
controls gene expression
now the challenge is this requires a
definition of cell type and this is at
least an hour later not so well defined
and what we really would like to get at
is actually a regression problem where
every cell has its slope we would like
to assess genetic effects in each single
cell because then we don't have defined
cell types now i could ask how does
variants in the german genome affect
gene expression in cell 1 to n the
problem with this model is it's not well
defined because as many parameters as
data points
and so the trick that um
anna and tobias came up with is to say
well you know let's capture
um the similarity between these
different cells
on the transcriptome level using a
similarity metric we fit a
covariance-based model i'll show you
later how that works it basically
captures how similar they are
you know that actually includes a
special case of discrete stuff so the
script would be two blocks these guys
are all group a these guys are group b
so you can capture the discrete nature
but you can obviously encode any other
arbitrary and specializations as well
and this leads to us to fit a very
simple embarrassingly simple linear
model
where we now take a vector which is the
single cell expression value so this is
the expression level of a particular
gene across all cells there's an
additive effect that let's just say you
know these are
these x vectors the genotypes of the
individuals where these cells come from
and that's basically just an additive
effect that's regardless of cell type
cell state and there's an additional
component where we now have one effect
size as a dot wise product for every
single cell
and as mentioned before this is not
identifiable because you have as many
parameters in this model as you can
easily see as if data points now the way
to make it interpretable or
identifiable is to put a multivariate
normal prior on this gamma matrix that
exactly comes from this covariance i
mentioned before
and it essentially ties together the
effective degrees of freedom now if you
have a block structure you would have
only two possible values but you can
encode arbitrary assumptions about
sharing or similarity between effect
sizes across cells
and and there is a the way we estimate
the sigma is actually we use a matrix
equation with single cell analysis so we
fit one of these sparse factors models
and use a couple of factors that's
important because it creates a low rank
covariance if this guy is low rank the
problem becomes tractable even for tens
of thousands of cells otherwise
you're faced with inverting a very very
big matrix which is in practice not
possible and we also control for repeat
structure so we include this relatedness
component there's another random effect
matrix that accounts for the fact that
multiple cells observed from the same
person that's also important factor
because otherwise you have double
counting on this space and we can do
efficient inference by exploiting the
lowering structure of this i'm not going
to go into detail but you know it's
basically low rank covariance matrix
that you can invert efficiently and and
deal with that
and this is just to show that this
works compared to other methods
so what we're showing here is basically
our approach in blue and what we're
looking at is power for recovering these
interactions so interactions is really
this component non-zero
interaction effects between genetics and
cell state
and
and what i'm showing you here is in the
one hand you know the variance explains
the more more bands you have the more
power that's easy but what's very
interesting is basically how many
environmental factors and what these
individual ranks that make up a
covariance matrix really explain g by c
in the simulation and the comparison
partner is just fitting a simple linear
interaction model where you test one
factor at a time you know as a
conventional interaction test which
obviously really suffers from a multiple
testing problem on the one hand that you
you test more and more environments and
you really see that you gain power
particularly for complex interactions
when you have many many environments
that that drive that signal
so does that also matter in practice
here's one example so i'm talking
focusing now just on these neurons the
dopaminergic neurons just the
subpopulation here
that we lump previously all together you
know although they were
originating from different days of
differentiation with and without
treatment there's clearly some
substructure going on here biologically
speaking
and the first thing we asked is
basically does this continuous modeling
help
and what i'm comparing here is
basically just using these low rank
composition of cell states for finding
interactions the resolution is a little
bit poorer but this is the x-axis
versus you know discretizing data so the
first is i just use these three
conditions and then we just use
clustering 9 clusters 18 clusters and
and and so forth so maybe just
discretizing your data in different
groups and doing a pairwise standard
test
and what's i think quite nicely to see
is you really get more power by using
this continuous modeling actually quite
a bit and you know if you discretize
even if you over cluster data heavily
you only get a fraction of this
discovery so the same results with cn
simulations also hold on real data and
the reason really being that even if you
discretize you don't capture really the
sharing or similarity between these
different clusters yeah you assume that
they're all independent which obviously
doesn't really hold there's sort of
shared reflects in across those
and i just also want to show you a
little bit about how this works in
practice
so these are four eqtl genes and what
i'm showing here in color
is not the expression level of these
genes but the estimated effect sizes so
this model estimates in every single
cell a genetic effect size
and again that's basically done by
sharing pool information across all
other cells so their strong assumptions
inherent that's important to realize but
essentially we can really see that you
know there are some
effects that sort of look at particular
subpopulations of cells
in other equitails of other
subpopulations of cells although these
are all the same cell type all different
neurons and in going forward and
actually we cluster genes by their
effect size profiles we discover a
number of regular patterns for example
here is a number of regulator variants
that are only active in this top
population others own this tiny
population the bottom and so forth so i
think there's there's really strong
evidence
that you need to look at the right
cellular subset and cell type to look as
regulatory variants that is definitely
not just one effect that we can lump
together
i want to um close this part by just
making one tentative and this is this is
sort of early days observation that is
also matters for disease variants so for
example look at um co-localization with
sleeplessness insomnia this is another
gba set you can really see that you only
actually find overlaps with
eqtl associations if you look at this
subpopulation that actually comes out
from from from from from our model based
approach so this also actually really
matters for for analytic and disease
variants in going forward
okay so let me sum up this part
i think i try to convince you of two
pieces the one is that population scale
single cell sequencing is a useful tool
and and we can particularly using
pooling really scale this to really look
at hundreds of people and i think that's
that's much more
in this space and i've also shown you
one idea how we can really use
the full data set to model effects at
single cell type we we have to be
sharing they're actually interesting
questions also about double dipping in
this i'm happy to discuss that offline
or in questions
um
but it really allows you to share effect
sizes and statistical evidence across
cells and you can mitigate
the definition of cell types i think
it's quite interesting because if you
think about cell types being defined by
function
you could even argue that you really
want to cluster cells based on these
genetic effect size profiles to define
what cell types are rather than on their
distance on some on some view map or tcd
plot i think that's a that's an
interesting direction to to go into
i would like to take a few more minutes
to just tell you what we're doing now
and actually this is
um early days for us and i'm very
excited to hear your thoughts what we
are now interested in is you know i
talked about variant to gene and this is
something
we can do you know using natural genetic
variation that we explore these are
typically small effects
and what's the next question is how can
we get the downstream players in these
networks how do we get the
effects downstream pathways and so forth
and you know in other words trans
effects of of these variants and you
know mapping trans effects is
notoriously difficult using population
data
so what we are now doing is essentially
combining these ideas of pooling this is
joined back with leo park the sanger
of pooled ips cell lines with crispr
perturbations so we're now looking at 26
donors that's roughly what we have right
now 34 lines so these are multiple
lines from the same person
and we then
combine these different lines with um 7
000 plus
targeted crispr eye perturbations that
all have either moderate or strong
effect on phenotypes so they they have
phenotypic effects
and then we sequence those at different
days of of after perturbation stimulus
defending effect sizes but what's really
important is in the end what we get is a
matrix
where every row is a cell and for each
of these cells we know now which donor
these
transcriptome profiles come from but we
also know the presence or absence of a
perturbation state now so you can really
now start tingling together you know
donor of origin effects and variation
that's present in the population with
obviously the effect of of this crispr
eye perturbations
and there's a number of interesting
modeling questions that one can tackle
on think about what what do you get from
these designs yeah and you know i just
want to show you two examples of one is
because it's genome scale we can
actually look at how similar are two
targets if we knock out two genes then
we can ask you know what's the sharing
between target effect profiles because
we have thousands of those and what
we're seeing in at the moment is that
many of these actually similarity
between two phenotypic effects of two
knockouts is different by protein
complexes this very very strong
structure about a co-complex membership
those genes which behave similar if you
knock them out they share complex
memberships which is i think something
that's partially known but we cannot
really look at this in ips cells at
scale and there's also lots of
interesting gaps where there's no known
complex membership reasons that we can
look into
what i'm more excited about is the fact
that we can use these multiple donors
so if we look at the umap of this data
the core structure is actually line
so there's strong donor effects remember
although these are pooled
and the line effects are actually
stronger
than the than the individual
perturbations these crispr perturbations
and this leads us to thinking about you
know re
reactivating old ideas we had quite a
few years ago actually video following
up and we just talked to think about
whether we can exploit these multiple
donor components to to fit graphical
models using you know building on
independent causal mechanisms principles
so the key core idea being that you know
the causal graph should be invariant
across these different people
and whether we can use that because we
basically have in a very controlled
condition now data from many many many
individuals and we can look at whether
we can look at these invariants and
something that kind of lab has been
following up it's actually something we
quite a few years ago discovered in in
other contexts in yeast that basically
invariants to different contexts
stimulus and other elements really helps
for causation way before this was
statistically established and this is i
think a very useful principle to think
about when we when we talk about
modeling this data these these
invariances
and the moment where we're doing this is
by by fitting um
causal graphs that
explain variation individual nodes which
are genes by parents
and
if we have a regularizer that basically
accounts for this the graph structure
which we which we which we
uh relax using an l1 constraint to
optimize over possible dags
and then we can obviously also include
intervention effects because if you
intervene in a particular variable you
break the the causal independence
assumptions and there's there's
interesting interesting results to that
and when we you know we get graphs out
of that what the moment doing is we're
taking these icm inferences and taking
the next experiments to validate you
know whether these things are real which
i can't show results for but i think
it's it's an interesting approach to
think about how we can use these in
variances for causal discovery and maybe
that's a contribution for the next
coffee break and with this i want to end
here
i think i acknowledge people along the
way but um obviously really i want to
thank the whole lab collaborators i
think acknowledged dan gaffney and flora
merkler for the ips work and leopold
parts for this production work at the
end and let's just i thank you and take
questions
thank you very much
fascinating oliver um so coming back to
this uneven representation in the pools
do you worry about donors having very
different number of cells
and if so you know what are some of the
practical things you are doing to adjust
for that yeah i mean uh your question is
as well pose i think pools are a really
fascinating
tool but they have issues so this is one
pool that we followed over time every
line here is a is a donor in the pool
and what you can see they you know we
don't even start balanced that's
something to be aware of we just pool um
for maximizing throughput um but you can
see that here in this case two lines
outgrow all the others and and that's
something that we see routinely
we're just completely accepting it
what's something that was very
interesting for us observe i mentioned
that some lines more or less efficiently
create these neurons at the end and so
the relative cell type proportions they
don't care about pooling so if he plots
at the end stage day 52 what fraction of
the cells from each donor are neuronal
that doesn't really matter whether you
differentiate them independently own a
pool yeah and that's very important for
our purposes for looking at cell
intrinsic properties and many of the
properties gene regulation are very cell
intrinsic and apparently in this case
even this sort of differences in
outcomes pooling is is is fining and
quite robustly observed but i would
agree in other cases it might make make
a difference what we do in practice in
terms of dealing with this number is
really
account and propagate errors so whatever
you do
you basically have a huge additional
error sauce that's simply driven by cell
count
and depends on what model you do if you
account based model you really deal with
this normally i think it's actually a
beautiful example where count based
models make a big difference
because you get so much differential
sort of signal-to-noise ratio in
different observations and you can also
use other simple approximations it turns
out if you just use a multivariate
normal and have a diagonal error
covariance matrix and scale them with
one over square root of n the numbers of
cells you get almost the same result
which i think is sort of you know
similar to this sort of lima boom type
idea is that you can you know work in an
approximate gaussian space if you
account for different residual variances
but that's you have to do that and and
that's the price to pay but you know you
get increased
yeah yeah really interesting talk so
sorry if i missed the beginning um are
you looking only at annotated kind of
common
variant and if you are do you have any
estimate of
you know
the effect of the rare variants on
unexplained
yeah
and it's a very good question so
at the moment you know this is a it's a
matter of sample sizes um in in current
spaces we're looking at mainly common
variants
i think there's two interesting
dimensions to this question the one is
leveraging information we have from
other large bulk cohorts over to these
more bespoke assets if you want to go to
the tiny single subset that's great but
you don't want to you know go in blindly
so i think
um
re-weighting you know input hypothesis
rebating or other methods would be very
useful leveraging the bulk information
we have and not treating variants the
same that's one approach and and the
other approach obviously is is to
aggregate across variant effects for
looking at burdens but i think for this
we need larger sample sizes so we have
now efforts in the way to do
5000 people single sellers so you can uk
buy a bank and that's the scale i think
we need to really look at rare variants
in any shape or form yeah
oliver thanks everyone for the question
oh you had a question or a reminder the
picture that's what i was doing so we
have um a half an hour break we resume
here at three o'clock but please before
you grab coffee
go to the front
of the simons institute outside and
we'll be taking a group photo and we're
back here at three o'clock for the rest
of the talks thanks everyone